Europe counts 10 million Roma and yet  few people understand the realities of  their daily life the aim of Roma week at  the European Parliament is to shed light  on this pan European minority often the  subject of negative stereotypes the Roma  have the opportunity here to demonstrate  their broader cultural heritage the Roma  week in the European Parliament hardly  intends to show the dignity the proud of  the Roma culture and which makes you of  much more colorful any peas are trying  to raise awareness on the reality of  antigypsyism which encompasses a variety  of discriminating attitudes sixty  percent of the Roma population have no  access to clean tap water and many Roma  children have to attend segregated  schools we cannot be proud of the UVC  today we cannot be proud where we see  that the 80% of the Roma population are  without employment there is a lot of  work to be done to fulfill our values of  the European Union  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]